okay. The new year has not really started
until we've observed Donald Trump behaving
insanely on Twitter and he did just that.
So we can now say the year is, it has started
formally a Donald Trump tweeted threats to
Iran. It ran Iran, uh, and then abruptly switched
to asking for feedback about which UFC mixed
martial arts knockouts his followers thought
were the best of 2019. Totally normal, totally
cool. Totally presidential behavior. Donald
Trump tweeting quote the us embassy in Iraq
is and has been for hours safe. Many of our
great warfighters capital w all one word,
not a word I'm familiar with. War fighters
together with the most lethal military equipment
in the world was immediately rushed to the
site. Many of our war fighters was rushed
to the site. So problematic. Thank you to
the president and prime minister of Iraq for
the rapid response. Upon request, Iran will
be held fully responsible for lives, lost
or damage incurred at any of our facilities.
They will pay a very big price.
This is not a warning. It is a capital T threat.
Happy new year. Now this is already crazy
and we'll talk about the the substance and
a little bit. But then almost immediately,
just 15 minutes later, Donald Trump instead
tweeting about UFC mixed martial arts knockouts
saying just for a little change of pace, uh,
linking to who had the best knockout of 2019.
It was a poll by the UFC run of course by
Donald Trump's friend Dana white. And then
just minutes later, Donald Trump going right
back to allegations of fake news, attacking
people, talking about Bengazi threatening
stuff on Twitter. Why Donald Trump interrupted
his unhinged political rants to ask about
the best UFC knockout. I couldn't tell you,
is this merely the attention span of a fruit
fly manifesting on Twitter? Is this some kind
of crafted strategy? What is this? And then
of course the realization. Remember I said
at the top of the show today we are fighting
normalization here.
This is the intellectual capacity of a person
who is empowered to speak on the behalf of
the United States around the world. This is
the person who is making decisions about do
we bomb another country or don't we? Do we
put tariffs on that destroy entire industries
or don't we? He is pausing his geopolitical
threats on Twitter to post about ultimate
fighting championship knockouts. This is not
normal. I don't care how much his followers
pretend that it's normal or insist that it's
normal or believe that it is normal. It is
not. Now let's get to the subject matter of
these protests in Iraq because the, this is,
this is not merely unhinged tweeting. This
actually is a politically, uh, substantive
discussion. Donald Trump and some others are
framing the, what is going on at the U S embassy
in Iraq as an attack by a Iran on America.
Okay. Now these are the protests of Iraqis
who are sick and tired of what's going on
in Iraq. But these are also protests where
the tactics are ones that I find absolutely
disgusting and violent. So it's important
not to be sucked into Trump's narrative, which
corporate media widely has. While still understanding
that recognizing that this is not an attack
by Iran on the United States, doesn't mean
that we necessarily agree with the tactics
that are being employed. Lots of corporate
media has either been lazy or dishonest by
parroting this idea. The idea that what's
taking place in Iraq is Iran attacking the
United States because Iraqis are protesting
at the United States embassy. You don't have
to agree with the tactics or anything like
that, but falling for this narrative of an
attack by Iran on the United States, it's
almost like Trump is ramping back up to justify
at some point in the next six to eight months
attacking Iran.
Lo and behold, as the 2020 election is going
to be going on in earnest as the, uh, general
election debates are going to be going on.
Ignorant but malignantly dangerous in his
ignorance, ignorance and his arrogance and
the fact that he's willing to just go on Twitter
and say these things. So there's two sides
to this. I'm doing my best again in 2020 not
to simply analyze this as if this is how presidents
say what they think. The entire context of
this tweeting threats to Iran, tweeting about
UFC knockouts, going back to talking about
Bengazi and other things. The context is whacked
out and the substance also warrants refuting
and we've got an uphill battle for ourselves
trying to deal with this all the way up until
the November of 2020 election. Make sure you
are following the David Pakman show on Instagram
for more coverage of this and other stories
from today's show at David Pakman show.
Also follow me on Instagram. I got a lot of
messages, positive messages and negative messages
about the Brittany style crepes that I had
in Paris last week. Okay. I posted a video
of this. There are two sides. It's like everything
I do, somebody furious about it. There are
people who praised me for not getting those
a flower. Uh, the, the, the whole wheat flour
street crepes in Paris and going for the Brittany
style, buckwheat crepes. And then there's
a whole bunch of people who are calling me
completely beta for eating crepes that I am
like, uh, John Kerry, uh, a beta male Frenchmen
for even considering a meal. Have a listen.
I hope people are kidding, but if you're curious,
you can check that out on my Instagram at
David dot. Pacman. We'll take a break. I have,
uh, two Bernie Sanders stories coming up next.
The establishment seems to have realized Bernie
actually could win the nomination. We're going
to talk about that next. We're also going
to talk about the latest fundraising numbers
from the fourth quarter of 2019. They are
interesting for a number of different candidates.
Huge Bernie put break right back after this